one question I want you to answer about
is this is this experience helping or
hurting your confidence or what what
it's what it's doing for you personally
I think I think getting on stage is
really building up a lot of my
confidence because like you know me as a
kid I I
stage fright yeah couldn't even do
school projects without shaking you know
what I'm saying uh uh when we when I
first got on stage with you uh about two
years ago in Minnesota yeah shaking yeah
right I I have to like sit down
sometimes because I'm just a little too
nervous yeah but now
I don't do that like it my confidence
not only on stage has increased but the
confidence that it has instilled in me
just in daily life is helping a lot